as the son of a blacksmith you're more
used to making weapons than you are
wielding them the combat and Kingdom
Come deliverance is tricky to master but
now I've been in enough scraps during my
playthrough I can give you a few hints
on how you can prevent yourself from
seeing this dreaded screen
while you can get by by focusing on one
weapon in particular I have found it
much more useful to diversify my armory
long swords and short swords have better
sharp damage that is slashing and
piercing
these are best against unarmored or
lightly armored opponents who are
wearing something your blade can easily
pass through against bandits and Knights
wearing chain or plate mail they're much
less effective if you are stuck with a
sword though try aiming for an unarmed
at area like the wrists face or thighs
heavier weapons with less of an edge
like maces axes and more hammers do much
more blunt damage these can cave their
way through thick armor and helmets
using pure kinetic force rather than
relying on a sharp honed edge you may
have the fanciest blade in the land but
against the night in full play a cheap
heavy mace will serve you much better in
my experience a short sword and shield
is best for the early game to handling a
long sword works well for the late game
or when you're comfortable with the
mechanics that I'll go into soon with
maces and axes just being a great
addition to your inventory if the
situation requires you switch so before
you head into combat take a look around
if it's a giant in heaving plates of
metal armor coming at you maybe get that
war hammer of your horses satchel
[Music]
one of the more advanced techniques is
to use weapon combos each school of
weapon has a bunch of combos that you
can learn as you level up the skill
these are fantastic for extra burst of
damage and to get through an enemy
hiding behind their blocks one resource
to help you learn these risk free is to
make the most of the combat arena in
Rattay where Bernard can help you out
with some practice sparring it's going
to be a little awkward to jump into your
skill menu and look at the combo list in
the heat of combat so practice practice
practice once you've learned a few
combos you'll also notice that they
target specific parts of the body like
the long surge reeve under or wrist
strike can target the weak point of an
unarmed forearm or use furless carmaker
strike to an attack and armored enemies
open-face an important thing to bear in
mind and something that I didn't realize
with the first 10 hours of gameplay is
that a long sword must be wielded
two-handed in order to use his combos
axes short swords and maces can use all
of their combos with the shield
now this one seems obvious but try not
to stand in the same place for too long
if you keep moving you can keep your
opponent guessing and there'll be a few
moments where just a simple step
backwards will mean the Bandit coming to
your throat will whiff is swing it's
also worth keeping in mind as you're
moving around the field of combat is
that positioning matters for example if
your right side is close to a nearby
wall or obstacle you won't be able to
swing from that angle your sword can't
magically phase through any structure
nearby but the same goes for your enemy
too this is especially important to keep
note of when you're attacking in
structures keep your blades off the wall
another smaller situational detail but
one that I've been able to use to my
advantage is your positioning if there
are archers on the field if you put the
unfortunate chap you're exchanging blows
with in between you and the guy with a
bow mr. archer will hesitate and hold
his fire just be careful not to give him
an opening and be aware that when your
melee combat and falls you're a target
once more
[Music]
it's almost never a good idea to hold
down the blog button when bad guys are
whaling on you you'll lose stamina and
eventually your head in the early parts
of the game you'll be taught the perfect
block that's when the green shield
appears in a screen and you block in
time for the attack a perfect block
won't take any stamina allowing you to
save valuable energy - well in your foe
a perfect block also gives you the
opportunity to respond with a repost an
attack that the enemy can only block
with a perfect block of their own
learning the timing of this can take
some time but again your pal Bernard can
help you with that at the combat arena
now after you've got the basics you can
go back to Bernard and he can teach you
the master strike if you impress him
with your feats of warfare
the master strike is essentially a
straight upgrade to the perfect block if
you block an attack at the very start of
its animation then you'll have a free
unblockable automatic attack I'd
recommend getting this skill as early as
possible so if you haven't got it
already head back to Bernie at the combo
arena around 10:00 or 11:00 a.m. and
start throwing down once your pummel
striking bandits on the nose you'll be
glad you got this skill there are many
moments when you'll be outnumbered by
foes and while it might not be the most
Knightly weapon the bow can be your
friend if not a tricky friend to use of
all the weapons in the game the bow is
the hardest master but if you can manage
to get a few cheap shots in or disable
enemy ranges before they can roar on you
that can really even out a battle
especially when you're outnumbered or
like Bernard said in the early game
archery tutorial drop a bandit running
at you and then draw your sword on his
friend and while it might not sit well
with the Knights of chivalry don't let
those runners get away they don't always
keep running a few times I've been
fighting a camp only to be shot in the
back by an archer that I wounded and let
flee so if a bandit is heading for the
hills don't be afraid to plant one in
his back after all it's all fair in love
or more
[Music]
so those are five tips that'll hopefully
serve you well in the fights yet to come
as I said the fighting system is pretty
tricky so you may have some hints of
your own if so be sure to leave them in
the comments section below and for more
Kingdom Come deliverance coverage stay
tuned to games.com
[Music]
you